Conseil de sécurité de l'ONU ce 24
février a observer une minute de silence
y compris le représentant de la Russie
minutes de silence en mémoire de toutes
les victimes de cette garant en Ukraine
la France elle était représentée par
Catherine Colona la chef de la
diplomatie elle a répondu aux questions
de Fanny Chauvin à New York regarder son
interview
après un an de guerre il n'y a pas de
comparer en vue peut-on parler d'un
échec de la diplomatie certainement la
Russie a choisi d'entrer en guerre oui
et depuis 365 jours fait la guerre fait
la guerre d'ailleurs avec des méthodes
condamnales qui ne respectent en rien le
droit international humanitaire et le
droit de la guerre la diplomatie doit
revenir je crois que le message qui a
été adressé hier ici aux Etats-Unis en
assemblée générale doit être entendu
doit être entendu la Russie elle est
pratiquement isolée 140 pays lui ont
demandé de respecter les principes de la
Charte tous et de retirer cette coupe
immédiatement conformément au droit
international alors ici à New York la
Chine n'a jamais condamné la variation
russe elle propose un plan de paix
est-ce qu'elle est la mieux placée pour
ce pour se positionner comme médiateur
dans ce qu'on fait je sais pas si c'est
son ambition mais la Chine qui est une
puissance importante
c'est comporter ici au Conseil de
sécurité jusqu'ici en rappelant son
attachement principe de la charte vous
savez traditionnellement la Chine est
attachée à la stabilité elle ne se lance
pas dans des alentours et nous
souhaitons que cela continue ce matin à
la Chine a présenté quelques idées une
partie de ses idées sont convergentes
puisque elle rappelle l'importance des
principes du droit international de la
Charte de l'ONU et elle oublie et
malheureusement c'est quelque chose que
elle ne devrait pas oublier la partie
importante du deuxième message ici la
communauté internationale hier la
demande de retrait de cette eau la
Russie
occupe l'Ukraine
occupe une partie du territoire de
l'Ukraine illégalement elle doit se
retirer immédiatement si elle veut
qu'une perspective de pesso selon les
États-Unis la Chine pourrait armer la
Russie quelle serait les conséquences ça
arrive les conséquences seraient
majeures mais nous n'en sommes pas là et
si nous demandons les uns et les autres
les États-Unis la France je l'ai fait
d'autres partenaires également si nous
demandons à la Chine de ne pas prêter la
main à l'agression menée par la Russie
en Ukraine c'est parce que nous ne
voulons pas voir ce cas de figure ou la
Chine se départirait de sa position
traditionnelle attachée et la stabilité
et ce rapprocheraient au point de donner
ce qu'elle n'a pas donné aujourd'hui
c'est qu'elle ne doit pas donner je ne
veux pas qu'il y ait de malentendus la
Chine nous interroge sur un certain
nombre de ces comportements mais la
Chine n'a pas prêté ma forte à
l'impression en plus que peuvent faire
la France et l'Europe pour éviter que la
situation devienne hors de contrôle et
bien sûr qu'elles font c'est à dire deux
choses marquer leur soutien politique
économique humanitaire aussi à l'Ukraine
l'aider à se défendre c'est un pays
agressé qui a le droit de se défendre
pour recouvrer sa souveraineté et puis
tracer des perspectives de paix nous
l'avons toujours fait vous savez
l'attachement du présent de la
République pour suivre le dialogue
il l'a fait jusqu'au dernier moment il y
a un an et aujourd'hui nous voulons
continuer d'être un pays qui œuvre la
paix pour cela c'est assez simple il
faut respecter la Charte des Nations
Unies et ce que nous demandons c'est ce
qui est 141 pays ont demandé fortement
éclairement à la personne
merci beaucoup